hello and welcome to another of our
career interview series at eureka lab i
am your host bethany brookshire i am the
writer of eureka lab and today i have a
terrible cold
i don't know if you can hear it but i'm
still incredibly excited to be here
because today i am delighted to be
interviewing myron blosser mr blosser is
a biology teacher at eastern mennonite
high school in harrisonburg virginia he
is the winner of the 2013 virginia
outstanding biology teacher award and
when i was in high school he was my ap
biology teacher and one of the people
that started me on the road to science
and where i am today so i'm absolutely
thrilled to have him here um hi mr
blosser
hello bethany it's great to see you
again uh it can't be that long ago that
you were in my classroom
it was it was a good decade or so
um but anyway uh i would like to hear
about your job at eastern mennonite um
what exactly do you do as a biology
teacher and as head of the science
department there
that's a good question um
school starts here at eight o'clock
and i am always here by 6 30.
and so being the kind of biology teacher
that i think i need to be means getting
here early
science might be a little different than
english or math or social studies
instruction
because we have labs to set up we have
labs to take down
glassware to wash
we have so much equipment to take care
of that it takes a lot of extra work to
take care of that equipment so my job
not only involves teaching
and i love to teach
currently i'm teaching
two sections of 10th grade biology i'm
teaching a section of advanced placement
biology and i also teach a biotechnology
class that focuses just on biotechnology
principles and applications
so with those different classes that
means different labs that means
different equipment that means a lot of
supplies and materials so i spend most
of my day actually
not teaching
and so that's kind of what it means to
be a science teacher is it means you
spend a lot of time working with budgets
buying materials supplies and even
washing glassware
i will admit i actually never thought
about who washed my glassware in high
school labs
thank you for washing my glassware you
are you are welcome
so um so on a daily basis um you know
how do you prepare for class what kind
of
preparations do you do um you know when
do you do a lot of your preparation your
grading things like that
well once again getting to school an
hour and a half before the students
allows me to do a lot of the preparation
so that's when i take care of the
physical preparation for the day
also after school is when i take care of
the physical preparation of the day but
all of the grading
all of making out of tests quizzes any
kind of review sheets
all of that takes place in the evening
and so when i go home in the evening i
spend my evenings usually in front of
the computer
or grading papers
so in a sense i take my work home with
me almost every day
and so i try to think okay what parts of
my job can i do at school what parts of
my job can i take home
and those parts i can take home i
usually do take home
in addition i i
am working at
kind of flipping my ap
which means that i have videos that i
create and also videos that i find
online for my students to watch and i
post those
so all of that i do at home
because i don't need to be at school to
do any of that so
at school is when i do the prep for labs
and in the classroom kind of preps
wow so it sounds like there's a lot of
work a lot of work involved in being a
science teacher what made you want to
become a science teacher
that's an interesting question
i grew up loving the outdoors i grew up
loving what we now call the natural
world i grew up on a farm and
i would wander around the farm hundreds
of acres
with my bb gun but i would wander around
just this enjoying what i could see
and so i had this fascination for the
natural world for life for how things
work how things grow
and it was actually my high school
biology teacher
that first kind of
put the idea in my head that i could
actually have a profession
talking about and studying that which i
fell in love with as a little boy
so that probably was the first idea that
i had
when i was in high school biology that
man wouldn't that be fun
to talk about this stuff all day long
um and then when i went to college i
majored in biology
so i have my my bachelor degree is in
biology and i took a class as a freshman
called exploring teaching
where they had us go out to a local
school and i went to harrisonburg high
school
and we simply kind of shadowed a biology
i shadowed a biology teacher there
and i realized that that was something
that i think i could do and so it was
that freshman biology experience it was
my high school biology teacher and it
was all those years of growing up on the
farm that i think made me decide you
know what this is the profession for me
that's great and it's clear that you you
really
love
your job you love what you do what do
you love most about you know being in
the classroom and about teaching high
school students science
well one of the things i think i love
the most uh is the idea that
i can help others learn about that which
i am passionate about
um and what i mean by learn about it is
i can actually help them
achieve their goals
and so when i see my students i try to
think of what goals might they have that
that i as a teacher can help them
achieve
it might be getting into the college of
their choice but for me the ultimate
goal of course is to learn about the
natural world and that includes learning
about yourself
and so to me that that brings a lot of
excitement to work at that and to be
honest with you i think one of the
things that keeps the excitement in me
is i'm a risk taker
i like to push the envelope as they say
and so for me i i like that idea of
trying to be in a profession
where i'm encouraged to take a risk
and those risks are
risk that i think enable my students to
have a better experience in school
and so for me every day
is is trying to find out how how can i
take better risk
how can i
teach in a in a way that actually
encourages others maybe to learn more
and what i've come to is the idea that
my students need to experience their
learning
i think it's mark twain that has that
quote that says a man who carries a cat
by the tail
learns something he can learn in no
other way
i bet
so i take that to mean that if i can get
my students to experience science
they'll learn things that normally they
would not be able to learn
and so that idea of creating excitement
in science
uh is something that i that it keeps my
passion high and it involves risk taking
and it allows me to have my students
kind of
fuse collaboration with others with
scientists
with trying to be relevant
and also having my students be
dynamically involved in what they do
and so i kind of bring those pieces
together and and so that's that's what
kind of stirs my passion
so
you have a couple of ways um in which
you get students really involved in you
know in science um and one of them is
you run
discovery trips
um when i was in high school it was
called coast to coast i remember
and i went on one and it was a formative
experience for me um
what gave you the idea to do these
discovery trips um and what do you feel
their purposes
that's a good question i think one of
the reasons why i have tried to take
these trips is it's like the ultimate
risk
uh to take a group of high school
students for a month
across the united states
meeting with people
and learning science in the environment
that you should learn it in so for me
it's like the ultimate risk taking
so there's a little bit of adrenaline
behind that idea
and then i was surrounded by other
teaching professionals at harrisonburg
you may remember that were very
encouraging and very supportive and so i
think those early years of support and
encouragement allowed me to take risks
that i'm still taking today
one of the things that i've noticed
about these trips
is and they are about
8 500 miles
we travel in about a month
we travel in a full-size motor coach
we take some of the seats out we put now
we put have a generator on board we have
wireless hubs so we have constant
internet access
uh the students camp and so every night
we pull up to a campsite we set up our
tents we cook our own food
but the nuggets are when we meet with
professionals and so we meet with all
kinds of people that help us understand
a variety of case studies
the last couple trips we start by
meeting with wendell berry
and wendell berry is an author a writer
and so we sit around the fire with
wendell berry and have him talk to us
about his passions for the natural world
and then we start doing case studies
whether it's agriculture
whether it's water
energy
this year this past summer we did
technology
and we stopped at google headquarters in
california
and the students were able to see the
robotics car
that drives around without anybody
manning it
and we talked about what role does
technology play in our lives the last
night of our trip we spent on an amish
farm
so we got to see this dissonance and i
think probably the dissonance piece is
the piece that i am the most excited
about if you think about dissonance
dissonance is when things come together
in butt heads
they clash
and so that's the model that i try to
use as we cross the united states
studying these variety of issues
um
you may remember studying uh the
brucellosis bison issue in yellowstone
yes i do
yes and that was a it was a big
dissonance piece uh where we talk to
a rancher who shoots the bison when they
come out of the park
we talk to an environmental group that
wants to protect the bison and then we
talk to the park biologist who's caught
in between
so we like to use that model if we can
to allow students to realize that that
within the united states there's a lot
of exciting things going on
that we need to learn about
i've noticed that a lot of our students
today cross
the ocean and go to all these different
countries but never go past the
mississippi
so part of my passion is for students to
learn their own country
and this discovery trip allows them to
do that
so when you set about um setting up i
mean now you've been doing these
discovery trips for a pretty significant
amount of time when you first set them
up how did you find
the people and the places um to
stop at how did you go about setting it
up how did you get the funding um you
know how what how did you
handle it logistically
well actually the first trip was back
before
we did a lot
with email
and so we kind of eased into these trips
without having the technology that we
have today
in fact on the first trip we took a
satellite phone
just in case we needed to make a phone
call
and i remember that we were charged over
seven dollars a minute
anytime we wanted to make a call on that
phone wow oh my goodness yeah you know
it's just it's a whole different world
but the way that i started this was
simply by listening to the news
watching the newspaper trying to find
out what are the hot issues in the
united states that we need to learn
about
and i remember reading in the usa today
about this student who graduated from
humboldt university while tree sitting
in one of the giant
trees out in california he was
protesting it being cut down
so that gave me an idea let's meet this
man let's talk to him about his passions
that of course led to the dissonance
where i said so who would want to cut it
down
well it was the rough and ready lumber
company so then we contacted them and
that's how we set up that dissonance
piece
so it's it's learning about the issues
that face us and then trying to trace
down those persons that we think can
best articulate that for our students
that's really that's a an amazing amount
of dedication um the students and i know
because i did it get a truly amazing
amount of inspiration and learning out
of these trips what do you hope that
they really gain you emphasize
dissonance a lot do you hope that they
gain
critical thinking or you know
deeper knowledge of issues
yeah that's a great question because the
the essence of this trip
is for us to understand issues from
multiple perspectives to be able to hold
those multiple perspectives in our hands
and play with them a little bit
in fact i remember one student that may
have been on your trip
that told me when we got back he said
i thought when i went on these trips i
was going to find the side of each of
the issues we studied that i would
champion
now that i'm back
i realize that my mission needs to be to
bring the parties together and have them
discuss the issues
so that's really what i want is for
students to be able to see that there
are good
points of view on both sides of issues
and for them to be able to understand
the value of listening to multiple
perspectives
and not simply jump in one camp
immediately and ignore perspectives from
another position
so that's kind of the non-scientific
values of this along with learning a
tremendous amount of science
on the other hand i mean i would say
that learning to look at several sides
of an issue is actually a very important
thing when doing science you need to be
able to give up your pet hypothesis and
say yeah i guess you know this might be
more complicated than i thought or it
might be wrong you know you need to be
able to consider
other options it could be pretty useful
for science as well
that's true and i i do think it makes
them better scientists in fact one of my
joys is to take students on these trips
that i will teach the next year
they are different students
and so it's really exciting for me to to
teach students that have been with me
for a month
and
on these kinds of explorations we
understand each other much better and we
both kind of see things
differently than we did before these
trips so you're exactly right
um so that's not the only um awesome
thing you do to help
get students interested in science you
also run a biotechnology symposium every
year
what is it and what does it do
once a year it's usually in march we set
aside a day
and we invite the local schools usually
it's anywhere from 10 to 20 different
schools that participate
they send a group of usually upper level
students
a lot of them are students currently
enrolled in advanced placement biology
we come together for a day of
concentrated biotechnology discussion
we start with a keynote speaker
we've had a scientist from monsanto
francis collins from nih has been here
wow
augusto adonai if you remember that name
from lorenzo's oil he's the father of
lorenzo he came and spoke
we've had a variety of speakers that
come and they're they're pretty
significant speakers
and then
after the keynote we oftentimes have a a
time for students to ask questions
and then we break the students up into
two groups one group goes off to and
does lab work
now we have about six or seven labs at
one time
the other half of the students will go
to additional seminars and learning
activities
and then we switch the students
so about half the day is spent with a
keynote and a major idea the other half
of the day is usually spent working with
techniques learning more about
biotechnology manipulating dna running
gels
doing a lot of the more biotechie kinds
of things
this year will be the 21st
and
usually we have about 400 students that
come
so it's been very successful and it's
very exciting and it's just a fun day
that's really neat so you know you have
all these great ideas and you know it's
clear that you really want to inspire
these students um and you get a lot of
them involved in research how do you go
about making the connections to help
students get into laboratories do some
of them work in laboratories at
universities how do you make those
connections
well that's an interesting question in
fact i had a teacher stop me in the hall
a week ago
and
that teacher said you know i want to do
what you do
so can you give me some ideas of things
i can have my students do
and i looked at this teacher and i said
have you ever heard that you need to
bend your knees before you jump
and he kind of got this
questioning look on his face and i said
you know
you need to experience things before you
can
learn how to have your students
experience things
and so one of the values i think that
teachers need to think about is
themselves getting out
learning to know people people in their
discipline so for me that would be
scientists
so that i have contacts i spent a month
up at cold spring harbor labs working on
molecular genetics and met jim watson
and talked with him on almost a daily
basis
so
that's just one example of
a place that i've become familiar with i
know scientists now all across the
united states
i make it a regular habit to wander into
the science buildings of the three
colleges that we have here in
harrisonburg
simply because i want to learn to know
them
once i learn to know them i've got a
contact
and so as soon as i have students that
have a question or that would like to
work in a lab i've got 10 or 12
different ideas immediately because i
know people
and so i'm constantly learning to know
new people
learning to know what research they do
and then working to get students
involved in those different pieces of
research so it's a constant effort on my
part to push myself
to learn to know new people new
techniques new ideas so that i have
places for my students to plug into
that's really great so um have a lot of
your students gone into you know stem
science technology engineering and math
do you have do you think you have a
higher number that have gone on to that
than average or do you produce a lot of
students that have a really good
scientific awareness in general
that's interesting question i don't have
any hard data on that one um
interestingly enough my head of school
asked me a similar question very
recently
about do you have any idea how many of
your students are medical doctors
how many of your students are
in the medical profession or are doing
bench research or somehow doing science
research and i really don't although i
do know that i have a lot
there's a lot of students that i teach
that go off and do something in in a
scientific field which is very exciting
to me
because they keep in touch
and i get to find out and now the cool
thing is just like you
now they are becoming my peers
and so now we are actually working
together where you used to be my student
now you're my peer
worker
in education and that's very exciting
for me
well i would just like to say you
haven't aged a day
you look totally the same
thank you thank you do you have any
advice for say students who realize that
they love biology and that they want to
be a biology teacher um and do you have
any advice
for
um you know biology teachers who might
have you know big ideas for ways to get
their students interested but aren't
quite sure how to implement them
um
there's a quote i think the quote comes
from eleanor roosevelt i'm not really
sure where the quote really originated
and the quote says something like small
minds discuss people
average minds discuss events but great
minds
discuss ideas
and so i think
part of my advice would be for teachers
and students alike
to try to start having conversations
about scientific ideas
get off of the i'd get off of the people
thing you know
and get off of the the major events that
have occurred in science and start
having discussions centering around
scientific ideas
and that breeds a lot of questions
and if you've got questions then you
have a directive
and so once again i'd probably
advise teachers to bend their knees a
bit
try to do things that might involve a
little bit of risk
there's an old saying that says that
people will gather around a fire like a
house fire or a barn fire to watch it
burn
and so i think excitement breeds
excitement and so when your classroom is
on fire and usually it's on fire because
of ideas
then people will gather around you
one of the one of the ways that i tell
teachers that they know if they're
successful
is they have groupies
groupies or students just want to be in
your room you know they just want to
hang around because they never know when
the next idea is going to be birthed and
they want to be present
and so that's the kind of atmosphere i
think you want to work at
is to build anticipation for when's that
next idea going to come and usually they
come when i'm talking with students
and so students want to be in those
conversations because they could be the
birth of the next big idea
um for that so for students alike i
would encourage them to start thinking
about scientific ideas learn about
things that are current and today
and ask questions because those
questions once again will give birth to
ideas for research
and and by the way don't be afraid to
ask
i'm impressed daily how you can send an
email or call someone on the phone
that is a significant scientist and they
will take the time to talk to you
and to respond to your emails
i tell my students the most they can do
is say no
so i would encourage people to not be
afraid
uh walt disney had that quote that i
like i actually have it hanging on the
wall of my office and it says the way to
get started is to quit talking and start
doing
that's that's fantastic this has been
just an amazing interview i do have one
final question though
what is the weirdest thing that you have
ever done in the name of science
probably the weirdest things involve
putting things in my mouth
um
probably licking licking the slime off
of a banana slug in redwood national
park
to show students that the slime causes
your tongue to become numb
uh is it was pretty weird
we
had a bus licking contest at one point
where we would try to see who could jump
the highest and the way you would mark
your height is by licking putting a wet
lick mark on the window of the bus
oh one time i had a contest with a
student to see who could keep a pine
needle in our in our mouth the longest
and so i kept a pine needle kind of
perched up in my inside of my cheek i
think it was for three or four days
um
but then one morning i woke up and it
was gone
so i don't know if i swallowed it or
what happened but the student won that
bit
so somehow they always centered around
eating strange things or licking strange
things
well i i will say that actually on that
trip i also licked a banana slug for
science
um and there's still a photo of me with
my num tongue having like a banana plug
yes oh that's a great moment it's a
great moment so well jumping into also
i was going to also say in jumping into
a high country lake in glacier to show
students
to demonstrate that was pretty
significant the water temperature i
think was 34 degrees
so that was that was one of those
moments i won't soon forget
so or possibly repeat
well thank you so much um for coming on
and doing this interview you have been
an inspiration to me in many many ways
and i'm sure that you have been an
inspiration to many other students
as well so thank you so much um
congratulations on your outstanding
teacher award
and uh thanks so much for telling us all
about being a science teacher
well thank you for this opportunity
bethany it's great to see you again and
i'm impressed with what you are doing
so thank you for this opportunity